people are coming to you for the extra
service they're coming to you for the
expert knowledge they're coming to you
for help you're going to tell them all
the things that they need to get done
that they didn't even think about before
because you've been through it however
many times and for everybody it's
probably their first time and so that's
where people lean on an expert to get
advice and knowledge the only problem
right now is you don't believe in that
bigger future yet which is what we have
to overcome because especially the
beginning of a business when you can
Target people who have money or who are
willing to pay money it's just so much
easier than targeting people who don't
when you turn 15 it's a big deal it's a
big deal
no you did not yes no this is the best
you need to be in to be able to focus on
this so you don't have to have your job
anymore you could make enough just from
your current clients and Word of Mouth
power right now we're just too attached
to like the store people are still going
to do their parties they may not be 32
000 parties and that's a great business
to be in oh my God I'm gonna have 9
mirrors over this
I closed my business so this is what
happened a year into my first business
it wasn't working now so what I did was
I sold
I sold that one and with the money that
I made from that one I started another
one
and it was doing good
um it was a boutique a quinceanera and
Bridal Boutique I was doing really good
and then covet happened
so I had a close-up uh closed it a month
ago well a month and a half ago
I closed it and I sold the the stuff
that I had in there like um because I
didn't own the business you know just
the building itself I didn't know that I
just owned what was in there so I sold
that and
I mean I took a big hit you know I lost
a lot of money on it but I still was
able to
to make some of it so that's what I'm
that money that I have right now
I don't know what to do with it because
I don't want to use it for my personal
life because what I'd end up doing was
going in in work so I'm working that's
whenever I was talking to you the other
day I was working
that was great I love it yeah I got in
trouble too but I was like it was an
emergency yeah but you know that's what
I end up doing having to work for
someone which is hard I mean after
you've been on your own for so long it's
hard
so right now I'm like okay what do I do
you know like I'm stuck I'm lacking
discipline
um lacking
Focus
because I have so many things going on
um
just a lot of personal stuff and then
you know business stuff
like my house my husband walked out
um in April so you know like it's like
one thing after the other I came home
one day and he was going we've been
having problems you know so this was
coming
but it's like everything here and at the
same time
I'm like what do I do you know so right
now I'm working for this place I'm still
I'm doing retail and I'm like
um managers assist and but it's not
something that I want to do so my thing
is
um
how
can I get back into being disciplined I
mean I've always been disciplined but
right now I'm like I don't know what's
happening you know so that's where I'm
stuck okay so so you start with
yeah you take a deep breath and you
realize hey this is a this is a pretty
you've had some pretty uh life-altering
things that have happened and don't
expect to be perfect
while it's happening you know like when
I broke my neck uh on my tour last year
I was super frustrated too that I
couldn't do like I have a concussion
right I had a concussion broke my neck
in two spots and I'm in the hospital and
I had to cancel my event because that
was that night and then I told the
doctor okay can we can we just have
everybody who was going to come to the
event
come to my hotel and can I do something
there he's like no you have a concussion
like
you can't do this right and so like
slowing down was really hard
um I remember that the first night I was
able to go home I couldn't
I had to go to the bathroom at you know
three or four in the morning or
something I and I pushed myself up and I
know it's starting to get dizzy and I
was worried that I was gonna pass out
which isn't good when you've just broken
your neck right like fall on the floor
and so I had to wake up my wife to help
me go to the bathroom and they mean that
may not seem like a big deal but I like
Independence you know I like doing my
own thing and I couldn't do something as
simple as
go to the bathroom by myself
and so it's okay that it's it you have
to go through some periods of slowness
when this stuff happens you know when I
I I'm divorced when I was divorced
I don't know eight or nine years ago
um
I I wrote to everybody who was in my
circle my customers my friends my my
employees everybody on my team and I
said hey
um here's what happened I'm not
mentally where I need to be right now
I'm not as sharp as I used to be I'm I'm
probably going to drop a few balls
like it's not going to be as normal Evan
but I'm going to get back to it
so just letting you know this is what's
going on and and
it wasn't a total disaster
but just letting people know like it's
it's it's not even them it's it's for
you to understand that it's okay that
it's gonna slow down right now that this
is not you're not going to be in retail
forever
like in a couple years you're not going
to be working
at a retail store right and and you
deserve to have uh you know a a husband
in your life who supports you and
believes in you and encourages you and
it's a blessing
that is gone because imagine another
four years of being with him and
just lost opportunity cost so you you
will be in a different spot so don't I
wouldn't put
so much pressure on yourself right now
and I'm the go go consistency guy right
but there are moments where you have to
be more gentle on yourself and not
expect to be perfect on your schedule or
perfect in your discipline
um but know that you will be in a
different spot so it's now creating hope
for a better future so like where do you
where do you want to be what do you want
to be doing again like when coven's done
what do you want to be doing back to the
bridal store or something else
so I have a plan
um
I'm like I'm you know I know where I
want to go like when I turn my goalie is
when I turn 50 years old
I want to have a business where I just
check up on it you know I don't want to
be involved in all this starting up and
going back and forth managing the
business I want to be able to
just check up on it you know like I tell
my my kids while they're all grown up
but you know I just want to come by
there and pick up the check and leave
you know just this is
um but what I want to do is
I want to buy some small houses and rent
them out to people with low income
because I've struggled so much while
raising my kids you know renting places
was a struggle always or just buying a
house was a struggle so I want to buy
small houses nothing big you know just
like a single home
and rent them out to people with low
income
and then like
I'm looking at two or three years start
my Bridal in quinceanera store again
so those are the the two things that I
want to get back on you know but I just
don't know
if it's possible you know like the way I
guess the way I'm feeling right now is
just it's not helping me think but
that's really what I want to do you know
I want to start my store again in like
two to three years but come back like
with a bigger sore because right now it
was it was small it wasn't really small
but it wasn't too big
it was like a medium-sized well one I
want to come back and make a big sword
but at the same time you know I want to
be able to buy those houses and just
random out why why do you believe that
you can't start a bridal store again
you've already done it you've had some
success doing it why do you believe you
can't start it up again
I'm thinking that maybe two or three
years from now
it's not going to be
um
maybe it's not going to be a big demand
like it is right now because in this
area we don't have
a quinceanera we have bridal shops but
they're more
I guess my the people that I was selling
to it was more
uh Latin America you know people so it
was more of a quinceanera more than in
more than Bridal sure if I don't know if
I don't want to sound so confusing but
it wasn't a Hispanic base
you know and that's what I'm saying like
maybe in three years from now it's not
going to be such a big demand as it was
now why
um because like now what I'm seeing is
more people or
finding places or like just ordering
online and
I don't know I'm just I guess I'm just
afraid that it's not going to be a big
demand I know how to do it I mean I have
the providers I have a list you know
because I'm very
um I'm very organized when it comes to
things like that so I have all these
providers that I know I can go back to
in and purchase from but I guess I'm
just afraid that it's not going to be a
big a big demand you know what I mean
like yeah but this is the thing that you
have to this is what you have to start
getting excited by to figure out your
way through it because people can't
always buy online and that's fine but if
they're buying a wedding dress online
it's probably not your your target
audience anyway
people are coming to you for the extra
service they're coming to you for the
expert knowledge they're coming to you
for help because they don't know how to
do you're going to tell them all the
things that they need to get done that
they maybe not didn't even think about
before because you've been through it
however many times and for everybody
it's probably their first time and so
that's where people lean on an expert to
get advice and knowledge so uh the the
only problem right now is you don't
believe in that bigger future yet
which is which is what we have to
overcome because
especially the beginning of a business
when you can Target people who have
money or who are willing to pay money
it's just so much easier than targeting
people who don't so when you're at
somebody's wedding people spend stupid
money on weddings you know right people
people spend a lot of money on a lot of
things it's crazy right it's like they
want their dream wedding and they want
it to be perfect and and that's a great
business to be in
um it's it's much better than your other
idea like the the the low-income homes
is a noble idea but it's a hard first
business to do because you're you're
targeting people who don't have money
and so finding the the rental property
that will make you enough finding the
right quality tenants having people pay
you on time when they don't have any
money like it's going to be really hard
to make money in that business
not that you can't it's a it's a noble
ambition
but as a first business I would love to
see you
make some money again right so then you
can invest into other causes right
um You have to start thinking about what
what a good plan for your for your
wedding shop is going to be
and so
I would start talking to all my all my
suppliers ask them how they're doing see
what they're up to
um I'd be sticking around in the
community like how did you get most of
your clients before Word of Mouth yeah
so see what happened was I had a
quinceanera
in 2015 my daughter turned 15. so it was
so hard for me to find her dress like
the perfect dress you know and just to
find everything that I wanted because it
was one sword in the area and they were
so basic you know and I wanted something
different so I did everything myself
never in my life have I done anything
like that so I did it myself and people
loved it and they were always asking me
like different people were asking me
where did you get it from you know like
or where did you buy the centerpieces
and I created everything yeah so that's
what started my business is nobody
calling you now for help yeah
and so what are you doing with them
they're calling you and saying hey I
need a dress or I need what's happening
right now right now I tell them I'm
sorry I'm closed um and I referred him
over to the lady that bought my stuff
do you have a non-compete
um no so why not say hey I'll make I'll
make your dress
well the dress is what I was doing is
the dresses I was buying them and
reselling okay
so in order for me to do that I would
have to invest more money it's not
but what's the what's the order time on
address to get it in three months three
months that's a long time yeah well
what's it like this is the time to be
creative what can you do you've got
you've got customers coming like you've
got you've got the hard part
you got people who are calling you and
saying Hey how do I do this instead of
just passing them on to the person about
your store what what can you do to help
them like what did you do at the
beginning you didn't have so much
inventory and everything
well see this no this is what happened
because at the beginning I had what I
was doing was decorating venues because
that's I did that for my daughter too
and people wanted me to do what I did
for my daughter to do it for them
because it was so different so whenever
I sold that business I invested that
money and I bought a bunch of
merchandise
and then you started selling that and
then I started selling that instead of
me putting the work in I was just buying
and reselling
got it so so who can you connect with
that can make these dresses
faster or you can sell on commission
I could probably sell on commission
um but you see even that's what I
like I just decided to sell what I had
because it was just becoming so hard for
me because I didn't
in order for me to buy like
the big companies that sell the dresses
I have to buy
like
three thousand dollars
worth of dresses which is like three
dresses four dresses because those
dresses are really expensive but in
order for me to sell the dress then I
had to sell the bouquets
um
it's just a lot of stuff that comes with
it and people that buy your dresses they
want you to buy to sell them everything
like the bouquets the Tiaras
you know just like the whole I guess the
whole packages and that's where I was
making my money because I was selling
the whole packages but I was buying from
different suppliers
but the other stuff is fast flowers are
like flowers you know are you doing the
flowers in-house yourself no you're
working with a flower shop
well it was more of um I wasn't doing
any
real flowers I was doing fake flowers
okay great so but how long what's the
lead time on getting the flowers
together
um
it depends on what the person wants
sometimes two weeks three weeks so it's
not yeah it's faster like is anything as
long as the wedding dress
I guess it's not a wedding dress if
we're talking about 15 year old girls
right it's just like a uh like a special
party when you turn 15 it's a big deal
it's a big deal I said 32 000 on my dog
yes what yes wow this is the business
you need to be in I love it I love it
and I love talking 32 000 when she
turned 15. yes
is this only for girls or boys too girls
just it's just for girls when girls turn
15 it's a big deal okay
wow yeah okay so so but the dress takes
a lot of time great but the other stuff
is just a matter of weeks
yeah yeah so so then you could do all
the other stuff easily you could do all
the other stuff and see and that's how I
started because when I first started I
was doing everything from my house when
I got the permits I got them at my house
so it was like a home-based business
but then I just needed so much inventory
that I had to go out and rent a place
you know and that's what I'm thinking
okay so what if right now I focus on
taking a lot of courses towards
um e-commerce you know um knowing how to
use Instagram because this is the first
time I'm using Instagram mail that I'm
you know in your yeah in your group
so just taking this time to train myself
to use YouTube channel to do Facebook
lives
um you know maybe just take like a whole
year and just learn how to do this other
stuff and then come back you know what I
mean like save this money yeah I don't
think you need to though like I think
you can start right now like it's not
that you you shouldn't do Instagram or
YouTube will be able to blow this up and
I think you can even do it not just for
your own little not just for your own
town not just for North Carolina but you
could do it for America
you know and learning how can I Market
myself in in Florida right or in Texas
or in right but even for now you have an
opportunity like I want you
to be able to focus on this so you don't
have to have your job anymore like yeah
you could make enough just from your
current clients and and Word of Mouth
power right now you're just too attached
to like the store
people are still going to do their
parties they may not be 32 000 parties
forty two thousand how much did you
spend again 32 32 oh my God I don't have
nightmares over this
if you have Justin Bieber come sing at
your invite yourself you know what I
like he would do that he carried you
more
um anyway like people are still doing
their parties they may not be as big
they may not be as expensive they may
not be as uh you know they may not be
having 100 people come over or whatever
with with Kobe but they're still
it's obviously an important tradition
and people are still doing it just like
people are still having weddings and
Brides still want their wedding dress
and they still want their bouquets and
they still want their invitations and
all of this stuff right so maybe maybe
instead of a 32 000 party it's a fifteen
thousand dollar party or whatever but
they're still there's still room in
there for you to make money
there doesn't have to be a store for
people to go to the the thing that you
win off of was never actually your store
it's your heart
like you you you care about these
parties you care about these girls you
care about these families in a way that
probably the person took over your store
doesn't care as much about them so that
they don't care but it's a business as
opposed to something that's like deep in
our heart like when we start talking
about it you see your energy come alive
and you're happy and smiling
so I'll be looking right away How can I
make enough money from that business
so that I don't have to be at that job
and it may not be the same size business
as you had before yet once we get
through covet and all this and great it
can it can build up but you also don't
need it to be as big because you don't
have overhead you don't have a store to
have to go to and worry about I mean you
just have to be a little more
resourceful in that you can take
pictures of the things you know in your
home instead of them coming to to visit
your home maybe you order three dresses
that are kind of the most
common dress
that that is easier to sell compared to
like this crazy unique dress it's going
to be really hard to sell and you still
use all your suppliers because they
probably still love you
yeah
and they're probably stuck with
struggling business too and if you're
saying hey I've got an opportunity for
you maybe they give you a better rate or
maybe they give you faster timelines
because they want to keep their business
afloat too
if if I'm you I'm open for business I'm
at home and I'm open for business and I
can't do everything that I did before
but I'm but I still got the heart and I
still want to make sure that your
daughter has the greatest event of all
time and I'm the person who's going to
help you do that and here's how it can
help
okay
the only thing missing is just a lack of
belief that that path is possible so I
will you know I will think about it
because
I really don't want to give up on it you
know it's something that I love to do
and then I have another quinceanera
coming up in two years I have one more
daughter
you need fifty two thousand dollars
oh my God
this is amazing
um no you you uh
the next person that calls you that says
Hey how do I Esmeralda I need address
who should I go to
me I'll help you okay the next people
who who call you you say I'll help you
and then and then you put the word out
back to the like how will you
communicate with people just email or in
the Facebook group or just phone calls
or text or Facebook what like how are
you talking about phone calls and
Facebook I used to have a Facebook page
but I wasn't so good with it yeah listen
good at uploading with pictures but it
was that's fine no that's fine it's Word
of Mouth like this is a word of mouth
business You've Won because because you
have a big heart to do this
your lovable people know that you're
going to do a good job and you've built
a reputation for for delivering right so
it's it's like today I would contact
look at the past 30 people who bought
from you
and and call them and tell them that
you're you don't want to close down the
business and that you're open for
business from home
because the way it just spreads that
they know somebody who knows somebody
who knows somebody who knows somebody
and and it's they're gonna your phone's
gonna ring okay and I have one like I
have one quinceanera that they had a
postponed like
they had to postpone their party till
next year
so they want me to do it they want me to
do it so they're waiting for you know
they gave me a time but they want me to
do it of course and you're gonna say yes
I'm gonna do this not go to this person
who bought my store and so so yeah how
many do you need to do to not like how
many did you do in a month to not work
that job anymore
two two a month too
I mean it's it's a really good business
and I guess that's what drove me to do
it because it's
I get to make money I get to talk to
teenagers which I love doing you know
when I I look I get to just come up with
new ideas because everybody wants
something different yeah and and so it
was like everything was there for me and
how many hours a week are you working at
this place
40 40 hours a week
like
you have to
you could get those too today
you could put out if you if you called
30 to 50 people today and just said hey
you know what I'm back in business I
don't have my store I'm doing it from
home I don't have all the resources that
I did before but
I will care more for your daughter and
your event than anybody else in this
city and if you know somebody or you're
doing it do just keep me in mind
you'll get two
today
you just have to call 50 people
yeah and then you don't have to go
work 40 hours at a job
but
it's not that they're bad that the
company is bad but like you just you
know you can do so much more and you
don't have to wait three years for that
to happen and do real estate or anything
on the side until you get there like you
could make that happen today
oh what's the resistance to calling up
all the people who've worked with you
who've hired you in the past because
people know people and they have cousins
and nieces and you know second daughters
and all this other stuff right
what's the hesitation to just call in 50
people today who already know you in the
community and saying I'm open for
business if you know anybody I'm doing
it from home right now
I guess I'm just kind of
um I guess I was just depressed because
April came and I started getting phone
calls because what happens with these
parties is that they plan
ahead like a year ahead or six months
ahead just because it takes so long for
everything
for the whole planning
and I start getting calls look we need
to cancel I need a refund
um just one thing after the other
and on with some people I had to give
them a refund because I knew it wasn't
your fault you know so I'm I'm here not
making money and I have to give money
out and I guess it was just one thing
after the other you know my personal
life and then my business and
I just got depressed and I was like this
is not me you know so I told myself I
can't keep doing this and I started
working that's the reason why I started
working because I was like I can't be at
home just feeling depressed
and now I'm like I mean do I really
I don't know like I just feel like I'm
not that same person you know that I
could do anything
no no you are you're not this person you
are that person you're that person
you're not this person this is who
you're not but it's just it's it's
listen a lot of people have been punched
in the face because of covet and
everything else has happened right now a
lot of a lot of people and and that is
part of business you know stuff is going
to happen this is obviously a crazy time
totally outside your control nobody
predicted that this was coming
um and it's like just imagine where you
want to be in three years that's that's
possible you can have a bigger store
than you had before
and people still like this is part of
the culture and the Heritage and people
are still going to have like unless
people stop having daughters or
something you know like there's always
going to be a business for you
yeah
[Music]
right with your heart and care and yes
learning about Instagram and YouTube
might help you turn this into a national
thing where now you're getting orders
from from Miami and getting orders from
from Dallas right like you can orders
from across America and work with people
but you could easily get back to a place
where you can support yourself not have
to have that job get your two two
clients a month
just by putting the word out to the 50
people and and if they say hey we're
still uh we're still not ready like
October next year we'll do it or June
next to it okay no problem whenever
you're ready I'm here
and if you want to do it when your
daughter is 16 years old I'm I'm ready
for that too right yeah
it's a little bit of um
humbleness you know to
it feels like a failure going backwards
and it's but but look at what's happened
instead you've gone and got a job at a
retail store instead
right
I would I would call like I think you
can get your 50 your two clients
today by calling up to 50 people
and again they may not be as profitable
and you don't have your store and all
that stuff but you can still get that
business today
and you can start to this is all all
this is is just how how long do we want
to stay in the hole because you got hit
hard like a lot of you know the world
did and you're in the hole right now but
you can get out a lot faster than most
people
you can get out just how long do you
want to stay here before you get out and
in your head is like okay I'm gonna wait
three years here and then do real estate
and then build my store bigger whereas
like that could happen
way faster
if you wanted to
and it's just giving yourself permission
to to do it
and call the clients and it's okay that
you took this little uh almost got a
pity party but like the little time to
reflect and and
don't judge yourself too hard for not
being perfect and not
um
not being on schedule and sticking to
your routine and being like the the
ambitious person that you used to be
that's who you actually are this is just
a slow period like it's a small setback
which happens right this isn't just
straight up right it's a lot of this so
you're in a down just you can control
how low you stay down here and you know
I desperately want you just to call 50
people today
did we get our 50 or maybe you're not
working tomorrow because you just got
two deals from the 50 calls that you
made today possibly
hopefully and listen even if you don't
get the even if you don't get the two
sales right now
uh just saying that you're back in it
and you want to help people from your
home
uh we'll get you a deal we'll get you to
two deals next month like if you don't
get it today you'll get it next month
and that that that allows you to have a
a window for your job so that it's not
40 hours working for somebody else doing
work that you hate for years it's for
the next couple weeks because you still
got to make money you still got to get
paid to those mortgage all that stuff
um but just letting people know that
you're back you will get deals
and it's just accepting smaller deals
and building up
it would be like going back whenever I
first started you know I was just doing
them because people were asking me to do
them for them not because I I wasn't
planning on on starting a business yeah
I was just first I started doing it for
free with friends and family and then it
became a business so and you're a lot
smarter than you were then and you have
a lot more connections than you did than
you did back then yeah and you know how
to solve problems way faster than you
did back then so you can rebuild like if
my YouTube channel went to zero I could
rebuild a lot faster than the 11 years
it took me to get here
so same thing with you like even if
you're starting you're not actually
starting from scratch it's not like
you're moving to a brand new city
and have no idea what you're doing like
you already have connections and
suppliers and people who love you and
know you and want to work with you
you can rebuild it way way faster but
it's not going to happen if you don't
make the calls and it's not going to
happen if you are staying at this job
that you don't like
sure
that's true let's go Esmeralda come on
50 calls
yeah yeah
make the calls
you just got to make the calls
will do all right talk to you tomorrow
Esmeralda all right thanks check in and
see how you're doing all right thank you
much love
I kind of have I think a unique
situation and I'm looking just for some
feedback from you for your experience so
I am uh I'm a self-employed certified
financial planner
so I thought hey you know what there's a
lot of need out there for
the misinformation that's out there for
what to do for financial planning like I
hear it all the time so financial
literacy is really bad out there and
there's a lot of bad information out
there so I thought when I start doing
some YouTube videos start a channel
um hopefully grow my business as well
I'm in Ontario so I can only practice in
Ontario but I can get licenses across
Canada so you know I was looking at your
course saying who's your Market well
initially currently my market right now
would be Ontario people and clients that
I'm looking to attract would be more
like on the professional self-employed
bases like me that's who I work with and
higher asset values like half a million
or more however I want to get the
message out to anybody whether they need
to start an resp
or you know save for a house or whatever
they're probably not going to become
clients but you know they need the
information as well that's the one thing
now what I've learned is I just can't do
videos like I did a few videos and my
compliance to take them down they're not
approved so we're heavily regulated the
one benefit is that we have a lot of
pre-approved material that I can just
read word for word or put in my
intonation maybe change a little bit
however I've learned that my process of
approval takes about two weeks every
time I send something in and this is I
didn't know this right yeah I thought
I'd send something in I get something
back in 48 hours no I sent something in
two weeks later I get it back they make
some changes resubmit another two weeks
so I've learned that so now my I've
already figured out I got to send in
something one a day basically and have
something going so my challenge right
now is just finding the time on the
schedule like all of us how to do this
while running a practice meeting clients
all that other stuff yep so that's
currently
uh in five years time
I'd probably will be retired from this
and living somewhere in Europe because
we've always looked to be moving there
so okay here for five years from now is
to have a consultancy financial planning
focused for Canadian expats looking to
move to Europe for example I've already
got clients I've already done that so
I'm already in that we've been Taste of
Europe and that's kind of the long-term
Five-Year Plan so now my challenge is
how to merge these two together having a
channel on basically
my idea is like hey you know maybe do a
video Malaga Spain is a great place to
retire to blah blah blah and here's
someone we talked to that my cousin
lives there and then if you really want
to know how to make a plan to get there
go to my other YouTube channel over
there
which has like Financial Planning and
click there so the one YouTube channel
for today is finding clients with half a
million or more self-employed
professionals get the message out for
other things and then the other one
would be like five years down the road
to build it to have a consultancy and
yeah just to make matters even more
complicated I also became I was promoted
to the vision manager last year so my
other job is recruiting new Financial
professionals something a third YouTube
channel where how to run a successful
financial planning practice
right which would be attracting other
Professionals in the industry
dude let's go I love it I love it and uh
it happens in in your industry it
happens a lot of medical Industries how
much you can say how much advice you can
give uh you don't want to give medical
advice legal advice same thing
franchisees same thing they can only say
some things that the head office has to
improve uh so I hear you if I'm you I'm
first thinking about
what is the thing that you want to be
building towards like if your business
is is pretty good right now when you
your division head you're managing your
team and you're growing your business a
lot of it's still based off of referrals
anyway right now
uh and you want to be somewhere else in
five years that's the one I would
prioritize the most is let me start
planting the seed to set myself up for
success in five years and maybe that
becomes a three-year plan or two-year
plan because no obviously absolutely
yeah it could be a five year three year
or ten year who knows right but yeah
well but if you start getting tons of
clients for that thing it can help bump
up the the timeline and get there faster
because you got so much domain so build
domain for the right thing if you're
building a YouTube channel for you know
clients for your consumer business but
then you know you're going to be out in
a couple years it's almost not worth it
um well so one tidbit because there's a
lot of information I got to present like
for example I just have to maintain and
grow my current business because when I
leave I sell my practice to another
advisor so the bigger it is the better
it's going to be and you know it's it's
not just I can't keep it stagnant I want
to still bring in yeah so really if I
could get like 10 clients a year at half
a million that's fine that's all I need
you didn't give a lesson who are the
best referral partners for your current
business and for the Europe business
it's been starting now a bit after about
five years to get referrals it wasn't at
the beginning but I'd say it got most of
my referrals from the accountants that I
work with okay and what about for the
your business
I guess it would have to be my clients
start talking about it because one has
already moved there
so that would be a referral one is
working to move there in five to ten
years I don't really have anybody else
so that especially for your business
referrals are so critical I mean I don't
have to tell you that but you know for
people watching too thinking about who
could be good referral Partners if
you're if you're taking Canadians and
then taking them to Europe the the
lawyers who are experts in moving
businesses over the accountants who are
experts in Italy or Greece or wherever
you're going to go and send people to uh
those are great relationships to start
to build now
yeah and then that sets you up because
they could help refer clients into you
as well it's like oh okay well we
already have clients who are moving here
and we're helping them with the legal we
need somebody to help them figure out
their finances talk to Sir she's the guy
so building those relationships is the
fastest way to start getting that
business off the ground uh now how do
you do that with you're talking YouTube
content or Instagram content so you I
guess I could call them and say hey uh
you want to do a YouTube uh together
with and interview them and say hey what
do you see about people coming over to
whatever Italy and what are the things
that's that's the show so the show
because of all the compliance and
because of the kind of timeline that
you're working on the show is not
actually for uh the consumer the show is
having people on who are your potential
referral Partners it's a business
development show yeah so lawyers never
get asked to do interviews on anything
yeah so if you go in and say hey do you
want to be a potential partner for me
and maybe refer business to each other
they're getting hit up all the times
with business opportunities and like
you're just another financial advisor
that they're that they have to kind of
SWAT away and decide if they actually
want to do something with you but if you
say hey I'd love to interview you for my
YouTube channel that's going to talk
about how Canadians can either you know
invest if it's a Canadian Market or how
Canadians can move overseas that's what
my channel is all dedicated towards like
really you got a channel for that sure
I'd happy I'd be happy to come on and
then you spend an hour with them
interviewing them now you builted a
relationship and now they're asking hey
Serge what do you do like you're the
financial guy huh we might have some
clients for you yeah so it almost
doesn't matter how well that video does
it's the point is to not reach consumers
but to connect with potential referral
Partners so it's business development
for you
yeah yeah
that's right
is it anywhere in Europe or specific
countries you're trying to move into
uh well uh most are going to be in if
the the Latin speaking languages so or
the the southern coast of Spain Italy
um Portugal you know things like that
Portugal yeah yeah and the laws are
similar but different so you need a
referral Network yeah so one client
right now so I'm Eastern European by
background so the niche that I've kind
of fell into is that uh most of my
clients that I work with that are also
Eastern European Romania for example
that's where I'm from uh they've come
here they've worked here for 10 20 30
years and some of them have decided they
want to move back into Europe for
whatever the reason so they sell
everything here they go back there and
because Romanian is a Latin based
language they're picking Spain or Italy
instead of going back to Romania or it
could even be back to Romania but that's
kind of the niche and uh so far with
that one client that did it we talked
with an international accountant we did
all the paperwork we helped them set up
figured out what have to do with the
rrsps all that stuff so my idea was if
you're Canadian and it could be might
not just be an expat retiring it could
be like right now people are traveling
and working around the world so even if
you're like in your 30s or whatever and
you're deciding you want to go and spend
some time in Europe and learn the
language do you still need tax
information and what to do with your
rsps back home now I wouldn't be able to
be paid like I am paid now where I
manage assets or be more like a
consultancy fee almost like this is what
happens is we can set you up with us a
number here or whatever bank account
whatever it might be more like helping
people get there but I've got the
knowledge of if you're coming from
Canada
I know it's I know exactly what's going
to happen what you have to worry about
that's kind of what I'm selling here I
love it so it's then connecting with all
of the international lawyers who are
dealing with this who are the experts
and then you have them on your show
doing interviews to build relationships
and then my lead magnet could be the the
checklist this will be the top 10 things
you got to do if you want to move to
Italy or Spain or whatever right yeah
100 yeah and and the the goal that
you'll drive a lot more business from
the people you have on the show than the
people who watch the show
yeah so the goal is to have like if you
do a show a week over the next year then
you have 50 connections to International
lawyers that maybe not all of them pass
your business but if 10 of them do and
it's an ongoing source of business for
you that it's not just this one-off deal
right that's the strength of having it
they have people all the time coming in
that that builds your entire business
yeah
yeah
okay
International for me like I just
finished going through the Visa process
to get to the US and I had to work
through across the border lawyer to help
and set up cross-border Banking and like
it's a giant pain and it I I solved it
through connections you know through
people who were referrals like I didn't
know who the right person actually the
first person I hired was the wrong
person we had the fire to get somebody
to help us who had the right answer so
one of the biggest mistakes that people
make is they don't think about business
development in the content
so especially for you if it's heavily
regulated you can only say so many
things you interviewing a lawyer about
people moving over is a lot easier to
get through than you giving RSP advice
to people that has to be screened by
your organization yeah it's got to be a
totally different channel of different
mindset yet it is it is
consultancy but not financial planning
let's say it's like what are the rules
that you might encounter like if you
leave or do stuff if I talk anything at
all about financial planning
then I run the risk of my combining that
should be on this other channel yep and
that's going to be reviewed embedded
basically so
yeah so the show's just about hey I'm
Serge and I I love helping Canadians set
up in another country whether it's uh as
a second residence or now it's a
retirement residence and figuring out
all the financial elements to be able to
move over there and still manage uh
manage their their life and their
business and today I got a special guest
who is a international lawyer who
specializes in other legal aspects and
so we're going to talk about some of the
things you have to think about when you
move to Greece
yeah right and then so and that's the
show and then you just ask questions and
it's the same questions what do
Canadians have to keep in mind when
they're moving over there you know one
of the biggest mistakes that you think
that these people make before they they
come over there right like you keep
calling it a show though so is it a
YouTube like still videos you put on
YouTube or is it like a live show I
don't what is what is it yeah yeah well
so it's so that you can call it a show
okay so that you're not just making
YouTube videos it's like I've got a show
on YouTube and and I interview experts
to have them to help Canadians move
abroad and you're an act expert in the
legal side of things in Portugal and I
love the interview I mean as long as
your English is halfway decent but most
people at that point will have like if
you're a professional International
lawyer in one of these countries you
speak English it may not be your first
language but you can get by in English
um so you call it a show just to make it
more as opposed to like oh you know I
want to do a YouTube video yeah yeah
yeah it's like you have a show and this
is an ongoing thing that you're doing
ideally every week where you have
different experts on sharing their
advice and their story it's a it's a
really easy show to host it's the same
questions that you just keep asking
whatever you're curious about
um you don't run into the compliance
issues because you're talking about the
legal aspects not the financial side of
things uh
and then you get business from them
because they need they know all the
legal stuff but they need the financial
guys and that's where you come in yeah
and I was thinking like because I love
to travel and I love food it could also
almost be like uh it can almost be like
a travel food relocation show like you
know start off with because we do travel
a lot so I have a huge opportunity to
make my own videos while I'm there
um we go a couple times a year uh build
a database of it and say you know when
you're here you should try this stuff at
this place or we're like this is the
street that everybody goes to kind of
thing and then kind of get into that and
then from there go into the interview
aspect of it like I really I love to
travel in the food I'm sorry the travel
is great the food I don't know how much
you want to get in you know there's
limits on the food I'm half Italian so I
it's easy to overeat when I go on but
um
and it might even be worth like if you
can get I don't know who the top lawyers
are the top potential referral partners
for you are in in those countries but if
you can line up an interview with one of
the senior Partners there maybe that's
worth a trip on its own yeah that wasn't
scheduled and now surprise we're going
to Portugal next weekend to this
interview
yeah yeah no that's great yeah okay
really yeah it builds the connection in
a relationship and especially if they
meet you and they see you uh they're way
more likely to want to do business with
you
okay
yeah so now we don't need to have
a hundred thousand followers on your
channel no you're you're making a
Content yes still to help and it's still
gonna be valuable content but you're
making the content to help you grow your
business through refill Partnerships
yeah
it's uh it's definitely needs
Focus time on the calendar and that's
big the biggest challenge
um just even I haven't been able to
attend all the movement makers maybe two
two of them I'm always thinking I'm
going to watch them afterwards because
for whatever reason a management meeting
comes up or whatever and if I don't plan
it ahead I just can't get it done so I
think that's going to be my next biggest
challenge to
everything you say is great now how do I
do that basically take out the phone and
start calling and booking yeah you or I
don't I don't know if you have somebody
on your team or you have an assistant or
um or you can hire somebody to to help
you do it
um I use a guy named Bo and that's like
he books all the people from my shows
and I'm happy to introduce you to Beau
if you want or just you find somebody to
help you do the bookings because then
you you like even this I didn't book
this
my assistant booked this and now we're
here doing this okay okay I'm showing up
it's it's four o'clock surgery now we're
gonna do this let's go uh so to have
somebody do the Outreach and then put it
in the calendar then all you have to do
is show up it's a lot easier to do a
half hour hour show
where you're just asking questions then
all of the back and forth and research
and calling and emails and follow-ups
and confirmations and making sure they
got the link and all that stuff
and you do the interviews through
Instagram or some other way it doesn't
matter Zoom or whatever it's a mix like
this is an Instagram live so this is on
Instagram uh my other interviews you
know like Tony Robbins and Matthew
McConaughey you know we did on Zoom
so we just set up a zoom link but now
everybody has Zoom right like you have a
zoom link so everybody knows how to use
zoom now like that's one of the big
blessings of kova is we all figured out
how to use zoom
um so but that's pretty like that's
that's low wage work like that's not
that doesn't require you and your
sophisticated expertise usually someone
who's friendly and who knows how to do
some research
to go off and find these people and
introduce the show and then figure out
the time I mean it's Europe so it's
depending on the country you're looking
at you know six seven eight hours ahead
so it would be a morning show for you
afternoon evening for them
but that's that's an easy like if you
just have to show up for an hour and
it's all been taken care of that's a lot
easier than if you have to do all the
bookings
okay build the connections do some some
shows I won't be able to monetize that
at all until well if I do that uh I
gotta figure out because any outside
activity I also have to advise right so
if any other income that's not part of
this so it's more like Base building a
foundation and you know ready to go
because when I do uh sell the practice
there'll be some money to keep us going
for a couple of years for sure while I
build that other practice but I guess
having the connections in advance will
definitely help I mean you could you can
apply the same model to your current
practice right now yeah it's just you're
not targeting lawyers and accountants in
Portugal you're targeting Ontario or
Canada
no I mean even just Ontario if you
there's enough here
yep like how many accountants and
lawyers have been asked to come on shows
and talk about what like nobody
yeah well that's true that's true
a lot of Mis
information misperceptions even within
the professional industry like
accountants assume what what I'm what I
know what I'm I'm gonna say I assume
what accountants are going to say are
lawyers are going to say right so that's
part of the whole financial literacy
thing like let's get all talking and
make sure that the right information is
out there because now with you know you
can type anything in
people don't understand why I can't give
them an insurance quote if I don't know
anything about them it's like well go to
the dentist and tell them that you want
your tooth extracted without asking them
to do x-rays like it's so it's it's so
hard to in this transactional business
to get people to understand and that's
part of the reason I want to do these
videos as well right why it's important
so so I mean it's it's Ontario
accountants are the number one driver
for business right now then go make a
show interviewing Ontario accountants
and you can go drive to them you know
zones are not in like I don't know where
you live but you know if they're in
Sudbury or something maybe you don't
want to take the drive out there
but they're easy to get on their show
this is the thing like you're not trying
to get Elon Musk on your show or the
rock or somebody it's it's an accountant
in Richmond Hill yeah but nobody's ever
asked their opinion on anything for a
video and now you're the only guy who's
ever paid any attention to them and and
they're going to come on and now you
build a relationship together right like
it's a it's super easy to get a yes
in this kind of model and then hopefully
they pass on business to you and again
not everybody will but if you did 50
shows and 50 weeks you'll get you'll get
clients and the Beautiful Thing is once
you get it like once you have the
relationship they keep giving you
clients it's not just a one-off thing
they're they're always having new people
come in and they can always pass it on
the search
um and you build an asset in the show
that then when you sell your book you
could sell the show alongside the book
yeah yeah right and you can just
transition to host
so maybe for six months you you co-host
with the problem bringing someone else
before I I teach them teach him or her
uh the whole thing and uh moving on from
there yeah yeah for three to six months
you're you're co-hosting with them and
then they take over the channel so don't
put the channel off your name that
channel
that's a channel off of
whatever Financial yeah you know the
company name and then it could be
anybody you're just a face for it for
now
you start interviewing accountants build
the book I mean if the goal is 10 to 10
clients a month that's that's a year
10 clients a year yeah well I mean
because no because so basically because
I've got multiple things I'm recruiting
and the clients and I've got my own
client base don't need to get 100
clients here right but it got to be a
certain asset level like half a million
or one million plus yeah then that'd be
okay right so it's not that stringent or
hard to do that but it's just there's
multiple balls in here juggling
basically right yeah
so it'll be it will be a struggle yeah
if I do then it's good right well you
just need one good accountant
relationship to get 10 clients that's
not you're not coming in asking for the
Moon
my part of the pie and that's about it
right so it's completely achievable if
you even the I mean one show a week is
aggressive but even if you did one a
month where you went in and talked to
accountants and you interviewed them
to find out accountants in Toronto area
is not that difficult no no to contact
them like it's not International
Warriors that's so much easier
yeah email them as easy set up a time is
not that difficult and now they're on
your show and to get one person yes then
giving you 10 10 clients for the year is
easy and you're building up an asset
that then you can sell to the next
person it's actually it might be a good
time now to do it before uh the tax
season here in uh Canada as they could
say you know what do you want to tell
your clients that they want to make sure
they do before they come and see you and
then afterwards because you can't talk
with them from February February March
right yeah but that's what you moved you
moved to the lawyers yeah you know when
the accountants are too busy you move to
the Liars because Laura doesn't pass
your business too yeah
yeah
cool that's that's the stress so it's a
different kind of strategy than most
it's not the I need to get a million
subscribers on my channel it's getting
the right people uh on your show so you
can build your business sell it and then
build your other business overseas
that's right
that's right you got it I love it man
well there's your strategy thank you
trying to get the work yeah it's great I
mean it's it's actually a pretty easy
business to build
like you could start you could start
this afternoon
just fill up a list of all the
accountants in your area and just again
because immediate going to call them and
say hey I'm a financial planner do you
want to meet it's yeah I think
they get hit up all the time the
roadblock that hit me and you know it
hits in your brain is like oh man I
gotta go through compliance so it's
gonna take forever so it's kind of it
slowed me down significantly at the
beginning like I was all going oh at the
beginning I was making videos and all
that stuff and I was like and then I
send in something and they go and this
word should I go and they said oh we
looked at your YouTube channel
you should take all those ones down
because it didn't go through completely
and I was like ah
so
yeah because you got to be careful that
we're we're actually we're representing
that company even though I'm
self-employed independent it's under a
big umbrella right it doesn't matter
you know someone's still sponsoring you
behind the background all right so yeah
no I get it and any regulated industry
or like franchises it's it's very
similar so this is this is a good little
work around hack and actually would
perform even better especially given
your timeline of how quickly you want to
make it happen to do the Partnerships
and just get to refill business in to
blow up the company okay
cool man thank you all right well good
luck keep us posted and can't wait to
see the show Absolutely take care Serge
to see me coach another entrepreneur one
on one check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there how do I
get people to the YouTube channel like
how do they know it even exists YouTube
takes the most time to build but is the
most long-term brand building that you
can do